Chúng tôi không có phòng Israel cast ngay mi sâu thông em một khẳng đệng
Nếu ngày sẽ không chấp nhận bư thành lập nhận nếu Palestine, ông Niu Zoh,
gần ra phải được phi quân sự hãi chế đề, bao gồm việc tháo sữa tháng bộ hệ thống đường hâm
và sải giá phà mắt, gió một lực lượng của tảy,
phó có lượng phòng vậy Israel đảm nhận.
Tìm bộ sinh ra cho bộ cảnh Mỹ để chính dự thảo như quyết mở với lực lượng ông Đi của tảy
tại các gia lên hội đồng bỏa liên được quốc.
Sự thảo này bao gồm việc Mỹ điều chính muốn tự theo hưởng đề cập nhận nếu Palestine
nhằm kêu gọi của khu gia tham gia đam có được lượng.
Giờ, через Israel bài tỏ quân hại, về sự phía đổi này
và thẳng đệng trên nha viếp sẽ suy chi quên phủ quyết,
đối bơi bất kỳ lực lượng đà khu gia nào,
hóa đậm tại gia gà gia.
Israel cũng trong biệt, các biển pháp ăn ninh mừng giọc, lạc cần thiết,
đề ngăn mùi cơ súng đột tại pháp.